[Music]
calvary's here we got you Dom Roman get
out of here at the Trap
when you end a movie with a cliffhanger
of that magnitude something for you to
die you only do that when you believe
that your audience believes in you no
way I still think my plan sucks but it
was no easy task because so much has
been created in this universe and to tie
up all the storylines this character
needed to come back into the mythology
there's no Fast and Furious without an
amazing tag at the end a surprise
appearance as the law man pulls off his
balaclava and his mask and we reveal
Luke Hobbs I stepped on set of Fast and
Furious as Hobbes the legendary law man
saying things that only Hobbes can say
we're lying hard to find use some
[Music]
foreign